my ex fiance and I broke up about a few
months ago and we have over the course
of the last five years racked up some
debts and that's what we have um both of
our names in and I've been advised um by
family members is to go bankrupt and I
just kind of wanted a an outside um
perspective well uh what I would tell
you to do um if you were my daughter is
to go U hopefully with someone uh in
your family just to sit there for moral
support and not say anything sit down
and meet with him in person and say um
this is an ugly mess and neither one of
our Lives go forward easily with this
mess unless we together figure out some
way to undo the mess here's my proposal
to undo the mess